if you were looking forward to ps4  exclusive days gone this year you're  gonna have to wait a little longer I'm  Tony and this GameSpot news update has  been pushed back sony has confirmed that  the zombie game will now launch in 2019  there's no more specific window than  that although the game initially had a  blanket 2018 launch anyway that date was  last mentioned by PlayStation boss  Shuhei Yoshida at 2017 s PSX ceremony  Sony gave no reason for the game's delay  but said it will continue to keep fans  updated those fans haven't seen much of  days gone so far outside of some  trailers and gameplay clips set during  the day and night it's the latest  project from Sony Bend the team behind  uncharted golden Abyss and the Syphon  Filter series not much is known about  the game itself but you can revisit our  preview from the games e3 showing last  summer if you want to know our thoughts  on zombies and motorbikes  [Music]